hello again everybody Ramon rustles back
so that can only mean one thing more MLB
the show 18 updates today we're gonna be
taking a look at creative player mm-hmm
fresh new feature what's one of the most
requested features of video game
baseball history what's really wide
batting stance cream yes batting stance
create oh boy so you sent us some photos
of your batting stance I did not created
it yes I did so we're gonna dial it in
real quick well uh I'll go ahead and
show you guys these photos they should
be showing up on the screen right now we
had a front-facing shot and then we had
a side facing shot all right so what you
guys have seen those embarrassing photos
for me that's not embarrassing I would I
wouldn't go that far
so to explain to us what's going on
right so right now we are doing hand
offset so we give you control of X to Y
in the z-axis
okay so x and y right here and then if
you hold r2 and ill you have control of
the z-axis like this this dis feature is
so cool so your hands are like 50 right
like here and knit this is incredible
I'm in the game guys this is like ear
also feel free to leave your comments in
the comments below let me know what you
think of my batting stance its BAM and
waggle is 49 elbow 67 yeah I keep my
elbow goes right up that's pretty big oh
yes straight near it's cotton not as
like griffey right Griffey and Gary
Sheffield back in the day that was
a 90-degree angle like that bad Wow okay
so you can't arts you can control knees
as well yep
yes sir so everything from elbow back
elbow front elbow knee everything and
what's cool is you're basically you you
choose a batting stance and then you
edit from the batting stance that you
choose so if you want a bad extent with
a crazy back a bat wiggle you need to
start with a batting stance that has a
lot of wiggle if you want one with not
as much you obviously want to start one
that doesn't happen it doesn't have as
much now are there existing players that
you can get every face every single
batting stance in the game you can
choose and create ok so here's your
batting stance is a little off because
of time it looks pretty good that's
pretty much you that is where my back
elbow is that's pretty much you but
again we have a hundreds of batting
stances in the game so let's go home or
mess with us who has something response
invited would like something the funky
man I was gonna say back in the day
first baseman for the Red Sox had a wild
one Oh Kevin Youkilis Kevin Youkilis
that's it he had a wild yeah his was
batting stance I don't know if we have
the rights to him anymore so ok oh yeah
he's not running well that's fine
oh here we go here's a good one
and again heck x and z axis and then if
we hold our to an L I didn't get a
little crazy there we go Oh pull this
tension extension and you see we stop
you from basically colliding with
anything that's why you'll see that
calibrating so you see it won't let me
go down there it's like no now you're
gonna collide with the helmet so that's
about as crazy as you can make it and
hand rotation you can make you can make
wild stances but not something that's so
crazy it's going to break the play yes
like you won't be able to do anything
where the bat is going through the torso
right yeah your face and stuff like that
and so you see he has a pretty pretty
big waggle so like we think people are
gonna be spinning a lot of time in here
like a ton oh my goodness is a back
elbow so this is bring the elbow there
just front elbow so these are basically
some of the extremes yeah I'm just I'm
going I'm going pretty crazy even though
it's even if you go to these extremes it
will calibrate so you're not too crazy
baseball players athletic doing yoga now
that is the stance that is and then
again you know if you want to change it
we can easily change it how does the
stance is right Wow so what this feature
allows you to do is let's say you know
Trey Turner changes his stance in
October I'm just going here and edit it
yourself
yep and it will make edits ourselves
like if we see that guys are changing
the stance we'll just make edits and
then it'll be included in a roster
update for guys who like to create
historical rosters and maybe of the
hundreds of bad extensions in the game
you don't have them once you look right
you go any creature helps create your
own that's pretty cool
so it's gonna be featuring me think like
especially for the role to the show
heads out there they're really really
gonna come in here and spend a lot of
time and just do like you'd be four
hours in just experiment and the
experiment I mean it adds another level
of realistic Ness if I want to spend a
ton of time putting myself into this
game I can put myself with my legitimate
stand hey hey it's a its role to the
show as a true RPG you know
yeah the two are bills to get in the
back leg I there we go back leg action
and what's also cool is if you choose a
stance that has animations tied to it
like a guy has a certain backflip
anything like that
you'll still inherent all of that
information okay so lastly I want Aaron
wearing judge doesn't backflip
anybody who does anything kind of crazy
like I say up week or another player
like that who's a little bit more
emotion you'll still
inherit all of us van right now have
there been any other updates that you
can talk about today for create a player
other than kind of obviously this was
the the primary update have there been
any other updates you guys can kind of
talk about or mention I mentioned trying
to think if I could go in as many would
not spoil some stuff
so we've done a lot of work with the
skin tones and the color density and
depth in the hair and that's something
I'm just gonna go through and if you
pull up last year's game and do this
you'll definitely see that our skin
tones have more depth they have more
colors the granularity is definitely
there that maybe wouldn't have been
there last year right so our character
team going back especially on the darker
skin tones it I would just think it
looks a heck of a lot better especially
with the hair - yeah and I'm sure people
are gonna think this video and probably
put up some comparison yes they are this
year and last year yes they are and we
got the hairstyle in the game that
people have been asking for for a while
let's see if we can get it randomly cuz
I don't want to go in there I'm gonna to
see what people have been asking for
let's see if it'll happen all right so
we've we've cut a head we cut a head
we've done movie magic movie magic
we got dreads in the game we have dreads
a lot of people asks last year
especially on Twitter we made it happen
shout out to the character team not only
do we have dreads we have I think four
or five other new hairstyles in the game
which we're not gonna show you today but
we had to show your dreads do it for the
people it looks good we were we were
just talking about Johnny Cueto I mean
this I know it's create a player but uh
I can see a little resemblance and again
like the the skin to the skin textures
will create a player all the stuff
coming up the ps4 levels makes
difference and that's that's all I'm
going to show you well thank you
regardless you know I'm sure there's a
ton of other questions we have at this
point
thank you Ron for coming in thank you
for showing us create a player kind of
updates yeah can't believe we can do
some wild to do everything Wow crazy in
it again thank you guys for watching I'm
sure we'll see more of Ramon in the
future to make sure that's coming hit
the subscribe button for more and we'll
see you guys next time see you later